As anyone familiar with series creator George
Lucas' original Star Wars screenplay would
tell you, the process of making the first
film so special involved throwing a lot of
bad ideas away.
So while most of the series' worst moments
are confined to the three prequels, the movie
that started it all had plenty of cringeworthy
material going into it, which many of Lucas'
collaborators wisely fought to prune.
Appearing on The Tonight Show Starring Johnny
Carson shortly after Star Wars mania had begun
to sweep the nation in 1977, Mark Hamill shared
his own contribution to the script's improvement,
revealing one clunker of a line from the original
screenplay he talked Lucas out of.
"The dialogue was a little bit difficult.
I remember there was one line that I just
begged [Lucas] to take out of the screenplay—and
he finally did."
"I'll never forget it as long as I live.
I sometimes dream about this line."
The passage in question came up during a scene
in which the crew of the Millennium Falcon
comes across what remains of Princess Leia's
home planet, Alderaan, after it's been destroyed
by the Death Star.
The line Hamill protested came as a response
from Luke to a remark by Han Solo, which Hamill
quotes for Carson with a charmingly gruff
Harrison Ford impression.
"Harrison says, 'Look kid, I've done my part
of the bargain.
When I get to an asteroid, you, the old man,
and the droids get dropped off."
That line in and of itself wouldn't have been
too out of the ordinary for the swashbuckling
spaceman.
But what would've come next was pretty ridiculous.
"And my line was: 'But we can't turn back,
fear is their greatest defense; I doubt if
the actual security there is any greater than
it was on Aquilae or Sullust, and what there
is is most likely directed towards a large-scale
assault!'"
Even in a script filled with confusing exchanges,
that one was too much for Hamill.
"And I thought, 'Who talks like this, George?'"
The line would've still been far from the
worst bit of dialogue ever to be uttered in
the series—but you can see why Hamill wouldn't
want to try and deliver those words.
Hamill remembered pleading for the line's
removal out of a sense of self-preservation.
"This is really not fair.
We're the ones who are going to get vegetables
thrown at us—not you."
The presence of the planet names "Aquilae"
and "Sullust" in the convoluted line serves
to demonstrate just how much got chiseled
away from Star Wars' script on way from page
to screen.
In the original story treatment, Aquilae was
a fleshed-out planet with the real-world parallel
of communist North Vietnam.
By the time the movie was shooting, the names
had been reduced to a reference for the sake
of worldbuilding.
When Hamill prevailed in removing the one
line they appeared in, he deleted the planets
entirely.
The line that haunted Hamill isn't the only
part of Star Wars' original script that needed
work, and Hamill's not the only actor who
had issues.
"Harrison Ford, who plays the space pirate
in the film, at one point threatened to tie
George up and make him say his own lines at
gunpoint."
While the cast's complaints with the script
may have caused some friction, their efforts
worked to sand down Star Wars' rough edges,
making it so most of the worst stuff never
made it out of the editing bay.
It all goes to show that when it comes to
collaboration, compromise is king.
Otherwise you get The Phantom Menace—and
how many great lines can you quote from that?
"Issa big sea monster!
Jar Jar Binks is terrible."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!